the welterweight division is interesting
because I just looked at the rankings
before we came on and Kamar Usman and
kamzochimaya are up there occupying
slots like one and four two and four so
there's going to be a lot of movement in
the UFC's welterweight Division and I
know Ian Gary's got a lot of teammates
residing in that top 15 but dude I mean
this kid man the appetite for knowledge
like he's going to Brazil May 21st
because he wants to really wrap himself
around how they do Jiu Jitsu and then
he's going to go to [__] New Zealand
to hang out with Israel out of Sonya you
know better can get him now Neil magni
and everybody else better get him now I
agree he called out Neil magnney I was
like oh that is a tough test for him but
Neil's my guy trading with Neil's a you
know hopefully he's not watching the
show but that's not a tough for him man
you know this Gary kid is the real deal
man I'm all in